charlie morton with that wealth of
playoff experience has the ball for
atlanta and makes his second home start
tonight
dickerson swings and misses there's the
big breaking ball from charlie morton
and a good start for the braves
right-hander now he'll face starling
martay there you go
yeah he went around back-to-back
strikeout starts the night for charlie
morton marty didn't think so
ryze smile as he takes a left turn get
him conscious with the fastball
pull the string a little bit with i'm
sorry with the curveball and
couldn't hold up now nick knighter the
atlanta native heads out there for the
bottom of the first well you know he's
going to be amped up and that's why i
want to see the velocity i mean
he averages around the low 90s
cuny junior out towards center field
coming in is
marte there's marcelo zuna have a good
night last night three for four
homer drove in three one two pitch to
ozuna swing and a miss he struck him out
one two three first inning pitching in
front of family and friends at the big
leagues for the first time
well the adam duvall traveling roadshow
is going to continue here in the top of
the second he will lead things off for
the marlins to be followed by anderson
and chisholm as he takes on charlie
morton
three balls two strikes and strike
three duvall takes 96 on the black
outside corner
and miami has a second hitting threat so
now it's mickey with two on and one out
this is down the line is it going to
stay fair yes it will up and over the
wall
and automatic double so the good news is
they score a run the bad news is they
only score a run
next up is jorge alfaro back in the
lineup after missing
five or six days with hamstring
tightness second and third one out
and al farrow's retired on three pitches
strikeout number four
and now with nick knight coming up you
like your chances of escaping the inning
and he's over two morton strikes out the
side but the fish cash in a one-out walk
neither leads one-nothing after one and
a half marlon's a one-nothing lead as we
head to the top of the third inning
marlins have marta at first dickerson at
third nobody out three two pitched
aguilar ground ball into the hole
short diving stop swanson no play an
infield hit
and rbi two-nothing miami dickerson
scores from third martay takes second
and jesus aguilar now has a nine game
hitting streak to begin the season
with two one and two out here in the top
of the third so now it's up to jazz
chisholm
this is jazz with a high fly ball deep
center field ncr
turns and looks it's a three-run homer
for jazz chasm jr
a five-nothing marlins lead here in the
third well he got degrom on saturday
another all-star tonight charlie morton
he unloaded it to a big part of the park
straight away center field
a stunning turn of events in the top of
the third inning changes the look of
this game
five-nothing lead for the marlins braves
don't even have a hit yet
austin reilly leads things off bottom of
the third
austin reilly lifts one right field back
goes duval
makes the catch up against the wall well
beautifully done
he has had himself quite a series maybe
not with the bat yet tonight
and still warming up but a nice job here
he gets himself to the wall gives
himself
perfect amount of time to make a nice
leaping catch at the wall
still in first with two away and it
brings up ronaldo
already down five the braves need
something big to happen
how about a big fly i'd like it
in the air left center field martay
just admires that baby
[Applause]
left of dead center number five
[Applause]
and now freeman rips one down the right
field line that'll bounce off the wall
freeman takes the turn throw from duvall
is
in time adam duvall played the karen
perfectly
and freddie freeman is gunned down to
end the inning trying to stretch a
single into a double
oh that's what he'd like to have back
trailing by three runs
adam duvall telling freddie freeman it
always bounce
into the stand into the field of play
and freddie
can't believe it
[Laughter]
and now jorge alfaro leads off the
fourth inning against charlie morton
and got her to chase it well faro's
really had the strikeout bug in the
series again bad hamstring and bad luck
dickerson has a blue pit and miami has
two on with one out
well morton's had to work hard after a
one two three first inning
now he deals with martay
sharply hit to short second base one
high fee but ozzie stayed with it
and martay did indeed hit into a much
needed inning ending
double play he goes to the bottom of the
fifth five two
marlins lead off man aboard for the
braves charlie morton will
stand in let's see if he can get a bunt
down
pops up the butt knighter gets to it and
inciarte's all the way at second
what a break the marlins get right there
a double play so neither
one out away from qualifying for his
first big league win
but he's staring ronald acuna jr in the
face and ronald
hit a long home run back in the third
inning
stroke to center martay on the run look
at that curry over his head
that'll bounce high off the fence and
ricochet back toward the infield
acuna continues his scorching start
braves leave after the game tomorrow
they're going to drag him kicking and
screaming to the charter before it heads
to chicago
freddy freeman is ready to go to work at
the plate
last year's national league mvp has
this year's mvp leader acuna in scoring
position
swinging a fly ball that's it for the
corner that ball is off the brick wall
well played by duval and freddie's not
running this time
and acuna comes home to score to make it
5-3
duval came up ready to throw to second
and freeman just slammed on the brakes
and wisely settled for the long single a
one out
walk third walk of the night for aubie's
that brings up dansby swanson who's hit
into a double play and he's walked
line caught by rojas what a play by
maggie roe to take a hit away from
swanson
my goodness miguel rojas does it once
again
a couple of steps and a dive to the
backhand in the hole
this is a big big out ronald lacuna
junior a two run homer back in the third
another one of those here in the seventh
would get us tied
in the air that's well hit that's down
the line body
is gone he does it again
ronaldo magnus continues his
unbelievable role two more two red
homers tonight
and the braves have tied miami 5-5
but it didn't work as now freddie
freeman stands in he hammers ball diving
stop at second chism what a play to his
left throws to first for the out
wow what a play right there by jazz
chisholm that ball was smoked
race closer will smith will work the
ninth inning
he worked two days ago and had a perfect
one two three
ninth inning when the game went extra
innings hey he came back to strike him
out
cooper's down swinging there's the first
top of the order now and corey dickerson
and dickerson swings and misses
back-to-back strikeouts for will smith
smith against martin it's swung on and
missed
slider in the dirt barnaut has to flip
it to first which he does
inning over will smith strikes out the
side
in the ninth inning a man that made the
last out in the ninth inning will
be placed at second base and it's a fast
man for miami
it is starling martay here's aguilar
who's one for four in rbi single and run
scored tonight and aguilar
left field base hit marte around
third he will score and jesus aguilar
into second base marlins have a six to
five lead
replace your runner i love it paul when
it comes to the breaking ball
fouling off fastball after fastball gets
a curve ball out over the plate goes
down and gets it lines it into left
marte comes around to score
aguilar gets himself into scoring
position great head back by the big guy
cunha freeman and ozuno will square off
with yemi garcia
who will try to protect a one-run lead
swinging strike three beat him with 95
and that is out number one garcia right
back at him
so two outs tying man 90 feet away from
marcel ozuna
a one-two from garcia swing in a miss
strike three
it's a marlins win
they take the first three in the series
in atlanta
two of them in extra innings and the
marlins now have
a four-game win streak